[Music]
ariana grande and Justin Bieber's stuck
with you music video is finally here
and it is jam-packed with celeb cameos
I'm grateful the two tees the video for
a solid week dropping a few teaser clips
including this one featuring Tiger Kings
Carol Baskin yeah that's a thing you
know you cool cats and kittens
now Carol's clip didn't make the final
cut more on that later but a ton of
Justin and arias famous pals did don't
blink or you might miss Justin's wife
hailey Bieber obvi and Gwyneth Paltrow
Michael Buble Ashton Kutcher and Mila
Kunis Jaden Smith Kendall and Kylie
Jenner Ayesha and Stefan curry chance
the rapper Kate Hudson Liz Gillies and
re and Justin's manager Scooter Braun
damn that is a lot of star power
then there's this Demi Lovato smooching
it up with her rumored new beau max Eric
so I guess that pretty much confirms it
right
oh and no biggie but fans totally lost
their minds over this cameo
yeah that's re hugging dancing and
kissing la luxury real estate agent
Dalton Gomez seemingly confirming those
romance rumors that have been swirling
around since March I'm happy life is
good
Justin and Ariana announced their collab
last week sharing that proceeds from the
sales and streams of the single will go
to the children of first responders and
they asked their followers to submit
videos of themselves having fun during
quarantine saying that the song was the
prom song for all those teens who won't
get one this year yeah well one
submission that didn't make the cut
Carol Baskin hours before the video
dropped Justin tweeted out this clip of
the big cat rescue CEO and her hubby
Howard dancing to the track in tiger
outfits naturally as a way to hype up
the videos release but apparently Ariana
refused to include the moment in the
final video she tweeted for the record I
did not allow or approve this clip to be
in the actual video but nonetheless it
exists and that's unique when one fan
responded to Ari's tweet by laughing the
26 year old replied I am very glad
someone is laughing the [ __ ] heart
attacks I had over this it was like so
crazy after hearing that she and her
husband didn't make the cut Carol told
TMZ she was happy Justin shared the clip
and hopes that quote it doesn't attract
too many of the haters who have been
bashing us since being misled by Tiger
king yeah by that she means the various
allegations made in the documentary that
suggests she may have killed her former
husband on which carol has denied anyway
back to the music
[Music]
before the video dropped re hit up
Instagram opening up about how excited
she was to finally collab with beads
it's the most fun I've ever had in my
whole life
quote I can't fully articulate how happy
I am that we waited this long to do this
the duet thing this moment really means
so much more than it ever could have if
it had happened any other way or if it
had been any other song
[Music]